>>> NEW CNN
REPORTING ON THE CLASSIFIED
DISCOVERY KICKING UP A STORM OF
QUESTIONS FOR THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
A SOURCE TELLING CNN THE
DOCUMENTS FOUND IN JOE BIDEN'S
PRIVATE OFFICE INCLUDED
INTELLIGENCE MEMOS AN A RANGE OF
ALLIES AND ADVERSARY, IRAN AMONG
THEM.
MORE DETAYS IN A MOMENT.
MINUTES AGO, NO RESPONSE FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE IS IN MEXICO AND WAS SHOUTED
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS.
IT'S A REPEAT LAST NIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT HEARING THEN
IGNORING SHOUTED QUESTIONS ASKED
TO TALK ABOUT THAT DISCLOSURE.
LOOK AT THE PICTURE.
WHERE IS HE?
NEXT TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES, MERRICK
GARLAND WHO WILL EVENTUALLY HAVE
TO DECIDE IF THIS INQUIRY INTO
HIS BOSS DESERVES A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
HERE IS WHAT WE KNOW THIS HOUR.
THE FIND THAT SPARKED A FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION ORDERED BY
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND AND LED
BY A CHICAGO U.S. ATTORNEY WHO
IS A TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HOLDOVER.
TEN DOCUMENTS, A SOURCE SAYS,
WERE CLASSIFIED MARKINGS AND
THEY DATE BACK TO MR. BIDEN'S
TIME AS VICE PRESIDENT.
AND BIDEN LAWYERS SAY THEY
FOLLOWED PROCEDURE TO THE LETTER
IMMEDIATELY ALERTING THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES WHEN THOSE
DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND BACK ON
NOVEMBER 2nd.
BUT THERE IS ALSO PLENTY STILL
IN NEED OF EXPLANATION HERE.
NO EXPLANATION AS OF RIGHT NOW
FOR WHY MR. BIDEN HAD THOSE
DOCUMENTS OR EXACTLY WHAT THEY
CONTAINED.
NO EXPLANATION ALSO ABOUT WHY
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE KEPT WORD
OF THE DOCUMENTS AND THE
INVESTIGATION QUIET FOR TWO PLUS
MONTHS NOW.
ALREADY, REPUBLICANS MAKING A
VERY PUBLIC CASE, CONGRESS
SHOULD LOOK INTO THIS.
>> HOW LONG HAVE THEY BEEN
SITTING AROUND?
WHO HAD ACCESS ALL OF THIS TIME?
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAD ACCESS ALL
OF THIS TIME?
WHERE IS THE FBI RAID?
YOU KNOW, WHERE IS THIS BIG SHOW
OF FORCE TO MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
OTHER CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
THERE?
>> I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE VOLUME AND THE
DIFFERENCE IN COOPERATION.
I THINK THOSE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A COMMITTEE
ASK.
I GUESS AT THIS POINT I'M NOT
WILLING TO TAKE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S WORD FOR IT.
LET'S ASK A FEW FOLLOW-UP
QUESTIONS.
>> WITH ME IN STUDIO TO SHARE
THEIR REPORTING CNN'S DANA BASH,
CNN'S EVAN PEREZ, THE FORMER
PROSECUTOR PROSECUTOR SHAN WU
AND JAMIE GANGLE.
W
>> WHAT WAS DISCOVERED?
YOUR REPORTING IS THE SEARCH OF
A PRIVATE OFFICE, LAWYERS
INVOLVED BECAUSE THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT NOW PRESIDENT KNEW
THERE WERE SENSITIVE MATERIALS
IN THERE, HE WANTED SOMEBODY
SENSITIVE LOOKING AT THEM AND
COME ACROSS AN ENVELOPE, OWN IT
UP AND --
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO UNDERSCORE
98%, 99% OF WHAT IS FOUND IN
THIS OFFICE IS ABSOLUTELY
PERSONAL BIDEN MATERIAL,
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE THE
ARRANGEMENTS FOR HIS SON BEAU'S
FUNERAL, CONDOLENCE LETTERS,
WHAT HAPPENS IS AS THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH THE BOXES, THE LAWYER
WHO IS DOING IT FOR BECAUSE
THESE WERE CONFIDENTIAL FAMILY
MATERIALS OPENS A BOX AND THERE
IS A PLAIN MANILA ENVELOPE THAT
SAYS IT'S STAMPED VP PERSONAL.
SO MAYBE THAT'S HOW THIS ALL
HAPPENED WHEN IT GOT PACKED UP
SOMEONE THOUGHT IT WAS PERSONAL.
THE LAWYER OPENS THE ENVELOPE
AND THERE IS SOMETHING THAT SAYS
CLASSIFIED RIGHT THERE.
HE CLOSES THE ENVELOPE, HOUSTON,
WE HAVE A PROBLEM, HE MAKES THE
APPROPRIATE CALLS, HE SAYS TO
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES, COME AND
GET IT.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT WHEN THEY
GO THROUGH -- THERE WERE ABOUT
THREE OR FOUR BOXES THAT DID NOT
APPEAR ONCE THEY STARTED GOING
THROUGH THEM TO HAVE JUST
PERSONAL THINGS AND WHAT THEY
FIND, A NUMBER OF RECORDS THAT
ARE UNCLASSIFIED, BUT FALL UNDER
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT AND
THEN THEY FIND TEN DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE CLASSIFIED.
AND WHAT MY SOURCE SAYS IS THEY
INCLUDE INTELLIGENCE MEMOS,
NATIONAL SECURITY MEMOS,
BACKGROUND BRIEFING MEMOS THAT
COVER AREAS FROM IRAN, UKRAINE
AND THE UK.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WAIT, COME BACK TO THIS FOR
MORE.
WHERE ARE WE IN THIS
INVESTIGATION?
THE PRESIDENT IS OVERSEAS RIGHT
NOW WHILE HE'S SOUTH OF THE
BORDER OUT OF THE COUNTRY WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO WHEN HE GOT
WIND OF THIS DECIDED HE WANTED
SOMEBODY WHO HE COULD SAY WAS
IMPARTIAL TO LOOK AT THIS SO THE
TRUMP APPOINTED U.S. ATTORNEY IN
CHICAGO LOOKS AT THIS.
WHAT'S THE PROCESS.
>> RIGHT, SO JOHN LAUCH, ONE OF
THE TRUMP APPOINTEES WHO
REMAINED IN THE CURRENT JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN DOING A
REVIEW WITH THE FBI AND THIS IS
A STANDARD PROCESS, THIS HAPPENS
ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW, MORE OFTEN
THAN PEOPLE REALIZE, NOT JUST
WITH FORMER PRESIDENTS AND
FORMER VICE PRESIDENTS, SO THE
FBI HAS A PROCESS WHERE THEY
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE DOCUMENTS
TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER THEY'RE STILL
CLASSIFIED, WHAT -- WHO OWNS
THAT INFORMATION, WHICH
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY WOULD OWN
THAT INFORMATION AND WHETHER
THERE'S BEEN ANY HARM DONE TO
NATIONAL SECURITY AS A RESULT OF
THEM BEING STORED IN A PLACE
WHERE THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
AND CLEARLY THIS IS WHAT THE
CASE, WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
WHAT HAPPENED HERE IS HE AND HIS
TEAM COMPLETED THE INITIAL PART
AND HAVE COME BACK TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND COME BACK
TO MERRICK GARLAND AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FACES AN
IMPORTANT DECISION, SORT OF LIKE
AN INFLEX POINT OF THIS
INVESTIGATION WHICH IS, WHAT DO
WE DO NEXT?
DO WE OPEN A FORMAL FULL-BLOWN
INVESTIGATION AND HAVING SEEN
MERRICK GARLAND OPERATE, CHRIS
WRAY OPERATE, I THINK WE'VE SEEN
THEM MAKE SURE EVERYTHING IS
DONE BY THE BOOK, CROSS EVERY
"T."
DOT EVERY "I."
THAT'S WHERE I WOULD SUSPECT WE
GO NEXT.
>> SO LET'S TRY TO BRING IN
FACTS AND INTERSECT THEM WITH
THE INEVITABLE POLITICS.
THIS IS GETTING MORE ATTENTION
THAN MAYBE IT MIGHT OTHERWISE
BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND ALL THE DOCUMENTS
FOUND AT MAR-A-LAGO.
FROM WHAT WE KNOW SO FAR AND
KEEP AN OPEN MIND, THERE ARE
SOME SIGNIFICANT AND VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT FACTUAL DIFFERENCES.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN POLITICALLY.
WE'LL GET TO THE POLITICS IN A
MINUTE.
YOU SEE THE REPUBLICANS BRING IN
THE CONGRESS, INVESTIGATE, SEE,
EVERYBODY DOES IT.
HERE WE GO.
IN BIDEN'S CASE, FEWER THAN 12
DOCUMENTS.
SOME TOP SECRET.
HIS ATTORNEYS FOUND THIS
IMMEDIATELY RAISED THEIR HAND
AND SAY WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
PLEASE, WHAT'S THE PROCESS?
IN TRUMP'S CASE, 160 PLUS
DOCUMENTS.
60 TOP SECRET.
HE'S BEEN UNDER INVESTIGATION.
HE HAD LAWYERS SIGN OFF THAT ALL
OF THEM WERE RETURNED.
THEY FOUND OUT THEY WERE NOT
RETURNED.
THIS WENT ON FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS AND IS STILL ONGOING.
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE
DIFFERENCES WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
FROM A LEGAL PERSPECTIVE AND
WHAT ARE YOUR QUESTIONS FOR THE
CURRENT, THE BIDEN TEAM IN THIS
CURRENT CONTEXT?
>> FROM A LEGAL PERSPECTIVE,
TOTALLY DIFFERENT KINDS OF CASE,
I MEAN, EVERYTHING FROM THE WAY
THAT THE LAWYERS BEHAVED IN
TERMS OF IMMEDIATELY TURNING IT
OVER TO THE TRANSPARENCY AT
THEIR NOW SAYING THEY'VE
APPOINTED -- NOT APPOINTED, THEY
HAVE ASSIGNED A PARTICULAR U.S.
ATTORNEY TO LOOK.
HOW DID THE DOCUMENTS GET THERE
AND THAT WILL TAKE A LITTLE WORK
BECAUSE IT HAPPENED A WHILE
BACK.
THEY NEED TO TRACE THAT.
HOW SECURE WERE THEY IN THAT
PARTICULAR ROOM AND PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION, DID
PRESIDENT BIDEN KNOW THAT THE
DOCUMENTS WERE THERE?
DID HE HAVE ANY ROLE IN PACKING
THEM UP?
>> WE MAY GET ANSWERS LATER
TODAY.
THE PRESIDENT IS SUPPOSED TO
TAKE QUESTIONS.
HE HAS REFUSED TO SAKE QUESTIONS
DURING HIS EVENTS IN MEXICO.
HE WANTS TO FOCUS ON THE
IMPORTANT BUSINESS OF WHAT HE'S
DISCUSSING THERE AND WILL HAVE
MORE OF A NEWS CONFERENCE LATER
TODAY WHERE WE SHOULD GET
ANSWERS.
ONE THING HE WILL HAVE TO ANSWER
FOR, AGAIN, THE FACTS AS WE KNOW
THEM SO FAR ARE VERY DIFFERENT,
PRESIDENT BIDEN, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT, BUT, BUT
THIS IS JOE BIDEN, TALKING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, HE'S GOING TO HAVE
TO ANSWER FOR THIS.
>> WHEN YOU SAW THE PHOTOGRAPH
OF THE TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS LAID
OUT ON THE FLOOR AT MAR-A-LAGO,
WHAT DID YOU THINK TO YOURSELF
LOOKING AT THAT IMAGE?
>> HOW THAT COULD POSSIBLY
HAPPEN.
HOW ANYONE COULD BE THAT
IRRESPONSIBLE AND I THOUGHT,
WHAT DATA WAS IN THERE THAT MAY
COMPROMISE SOURCES AND METHODS?
BY THAT I MEAN NAMES OF PEOPLE,
ET CETERA.
AND IT JUST TOTALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> AGAIN, THE FACTS ARE
DIFFERENT BUT THE TOTALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE PART, JOE BIDEN,
40 YEARS IN THE SENATE, 8 YEARS
AS VICE PRESIDENT, HIS CALLING
CARD IS I KNOW HOW TO DO THE
SENSITIVE STUFF.
I KNOW HOW TO DO THE HARD STUFF.
I DON'T MAKE THESE KIND OF
MISTAKES, EVEN IF IT'S AN HONEST
MISTAKE, THERE'S A TRAIL, WHEN
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE REMOVED FROM
A SENSITIVE PLACE SOMEBODY KNOWS
THEY'RE REMOVED.
THERE'S A LOG AND GO OUT TO A
FILE.
NOW HE WILL HAVE TO ANSWER.
>> PIE UNDERSTANDING IS HE KNOWS
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO ANSWER FOR
IT.
IS PREPARED TO DO IT WHEN HE
FACES REPORTERS LATER TODAY WHEN
HE'S IN MEXICO.
AND THAT HE -- THERE IS A VERY
CLEAR-EYED UNDERSTANDING OF THE
POLITICS OF THIS INSIDE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> FORGIVE ME BUT TRUMP DOESN'T
DO NUANCE.
HE WILL SAY, SEE, HE DOES IT
TOO.
>> THIS IS THE PROBLEM BECAUSE
IT IS VERY HARD TO EXPLAIN.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
WILLING TO LISTEN BEYOND THE,
SEE, I TOLD YOU SO AND OUR
POLARIZED ENVIRONMENT IT'S HARD
TO GET PEOPLE TO LISTEN.
THE EXPLANATION FOR WHY THEY'RE
THERE, WE STILL DO NOT KNOW AND
I DON'T THINK WE'LL KNOW UNTIL
THE INVESTIGATION IS OVER AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE CAREFUL
WITH THAT BECAUSE OF THE DOJ
INQUIRY, MAYBE NOT AN
INVESTIGATION YET.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE FACTS
YOU JUST LAID OUT IN THAT
GRAPHIC, THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE
GOING TO HEAR FROM THE PRESIDENT
AND HE'S RIGHT.
THEY ARE VERY, VERY DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS.
THE TRUMP SITUATION WAS, HE OR
HIS PEOPLE TOOK CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND THEN MISLED OR
EVEN LIED TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ABOUT WHAT HE HAD TO
THE POINT WHERE THEY HAD TO GO
RAID.
THE BIDEN PEOPLE FOUND SOMETHING
IN A CLOSET ACCORDING TO YOUR
EXCELLENT REPORTING, JAMIE, AS
SOON AS THEY FOUND IT, THEY
TURNED IT OVER.
IT'S PAST TENSE.
IT'S DONE.
IT'S NOT ONGOING.